-Welcome back. We are
hanging out with Jane Fonda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Jane and I are about to go
head-to-head
in a game of "Egg Roulette."
Higgins, would you like to
explain how this works?
-Yes, James.
Here, in my hand,
I have one dozen eggs.
Eight of them
have been hard boiled.
Four of them are still raw.
You and Jane will take turns
selecting one egg at a time
and smashing it upon the top
of your head.
-Okay.
-You won't know which eggs
are raw and which are boiled
until you smash it.
Once you choose an egg,
you must smash it.
No put-backs.
The first one to smash two
raw eggs on their head loses.
-Loses.
-Ms. Fonda, would you like
to choose the first egg?
-Whoa, very confident.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
What in the world?
That was -- [ Laughs ]
That was the fastest --
That was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, let's go. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo -- No, no, no, no.
Here we go.
Now this is --
♪♪
-Slimy!
-Here we go.
That was the fastest
I've ever --
-Wow, yolk's on you.
-Yeah -- Wow. Wow, wow.
-The yolk's on him.
-You are officially the coolest.
Here we go.
Thank you so much for coming
on the show,
and congrats on your new movie
"Luck,"
which I have good luck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-Ow!
[ Laughter ]
Ow.
-You just grab.
I take my time picking it out.
Audience?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go for it.
-I have a weird feeling
about this one.
-No excuses.
-Oh, I like that.
Here we go. Come on.
[ Imitates drum roll ]
Hai-ya!
Nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, maybe that was a sign.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Laughter ]
-Unbelievable!
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait, I have to -- I have to do
just one for fun,
because I can't just let you
do this.
I did not plan this out at all,
by the way.
But, you know I'm -- look.
-What does that mean,
one for fun?
-One for fun.
-One, each of you.
-Can you break one on my head?
Please.
-I'm so glad you asked.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Two?
-Oh, two?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-[ Laughs ]
-The one and only Jane Fonda,
everybody!
Her movie, "Luck," premieres
on AppleTV+ August 5th.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around.
Oh, my God.